today's topic involves somebody we
haven't spoken about in a long time but
she had some interesting things to say i
popped up in my feet but let's talk
about yeah
bumble
bumble bumble bubble i'm sorry my bangs
are okay look i'm just gonna put my hair
behind my ears i'm gonna have to look
like a big potato head for the rest of
the video and you're all just gonna have
to deal with it
here's why i don't like bumble okay the
whole deal with bumble is that girls say
hi first
and bumble's like hey
you're empowered
you've got the control what's the big
deal it's just saying hi
hear me now
if it's so not a big deal to say hi to
someone with your thumbs on an app while
you sit on the toilet
why can't guys do it
no
no this is something y'all wanted
that is part of the whole equality thing
yeah
because we do it all the time
we say hi
all the time we already do it it's one
app
that you guys have to say hi
one app
one
and we can't talk to you and we can't
engage with you so you don't get creeps
so you're the one that has the power now
right
okay if you don't say hi that's
something that you wanted you can't
backpedal now nobody no we're not doing
this
um
last one there do you here's who's on
bumble
[ __ ] boys
sitting there dicks waiting to be sucked
thinking the girls girls should be
competing for them
but that's what sugar that's your
position
it's not bumble it's bumblecloth
that's that
if i put it in other terms that's what
you guys do can you put in inventional
terms yeah yeah wait
dear
under the sun
you're grilling yourself all right
you're waiting for the people them to
come by
and soak your
stop it
that's exactly what you guys do
so once we reverse the thing you know
everybody thinking you know you know
haribo has that thing once we reverse
the thing
not as it's all it's all [ __ ] boys
waiting to get these up
girl she basically saw women having the
choice to now make the first move when
she went
up
she said what women making the first
move
this this is titled
why i hate bumble and why every feminist
should as well no that's exact actually
that is
what
that they are the hottest commodity
that's like what do you got oh that's
your opening line um oh you went out and
said that
look at the pictures no how about you
no
no is right
that's a big no from shaolin
i'm not down with this construct
if again if it's so not a big deal to
reach out to someone why can't guys do
that for us
if that is too emotionally risky for
them if that is just like a bridge too
far that's not someone i need to be with
if he can't develop the basic human
interaction skills
to come to a woman and say hi what's
your name i saw your profile like
knows your name but like this looks cool
did you travel to patagonia is that your
dog something if you can't come up with
a hello and a question to a person he
knows absolutely nothing about
what what do you think that relationship
is actually going to be like
i feel dumber just watching this she
acts like
women haven't made the first move before
and had healthy relationships afterwards
in fact ladies
if you approach a man vast majority of
time you're getting a far more favorable
response than if we approach women why
because women are generally pretty
defensive around men
women are far more selective and so we
deal with rejection more often and this
girl's out here crying about why can't
you why hand your hand because we
already do it what kind of relationship
what do you mean what kind of
relationship you know what i mean you
think guys don't like being courted what
you think if you ask us out first or you
can be like yo man this [ __ ] is easy
you want to be cool yeah this [ __ ] is
easy you want to be quartered hey hey ma
go get my food
you think that's how it's going to work
what you think you always going to be on
the
bruh it's the entitlement like
especially in this modern age of life i
could do all bad i'm indp i get my own
money i get my own bills i get my own
place [ __ ] get your own approach get
your own man then nah he gotta come to
me okay so you a boss when it comes to
everything else and then afterwards you
turn to a little scared kitty when it
comes to dating fascinating [ __ ] because
you would never say this kind of stupid
[ __ ] when it comes to jobs
you would never say this kind of dumb
[ __ ] when it comes to your passion you
never say why does it make you first
move on me it's okay to go apply
not everyone gets head hunted not
everyone not everybody gets counted
that's that's a fact and guess what you
could get head hunted and you could go
apply you could do both that's the
beauty of the world
and it's not because you apply to the
job that they don't want to treat you
well
that's ridiculous
the job went to get you and you're like
ugh and you know what there's going to
be comments below of people who said you
know what i approached my man that were
married seven years later my girl
approached me
my girl approached me and how many years
has it been
my my girl got out of how many years has
it been 22
my my girl got it got out of the friend
zone there you go she got out of the
friends there you go put in that work
guys if you guys are enjoying today's
video be sure to like and comment like
like it comment it helps out that
algorithm you're watching it for free we
provide you with daily content just like
the video and if you like the merch get
them earned and if you wanted 50 of
people watch the videos and don't
subscribe stop it you're already here
let's have a good laugh and let's
subscribe click okay ring the bell
because like i've always said men are
hunters right
and when you picture a hunter out on the
savannah what happens if he has this
idea that the wildebeest should come to
him
probably he's going to starve to death
right that's not going to go super well
for him when people use these like food
analogies for the wilderness i always
find it so cringe so what [ __ ] you
think you're something to be devoured
and then like picked apart and then on
to the next animal yeah is that it
because you know what a lion doesn't
stay committed to one wildebeest he just
he goes and he [ __ ] everything else up
is that what you're saying we doing now
is that what we're doing let's use an
animal analogy let's go we [ __ ]
everything then and you're supposed to
accept it because [ __ ] that's your
place
no
oh all of a sudden animal analogies
don't don't fit right people love making
animal references well in the animal
kingdom uh the matriarch is the yeah and
she gotta get [ __ ] and ran through by
every person in the tribe you wanna do
that
you know what's funny as well with the
the the when did they put the lion
analogy with this [ __ ] i love that yeah
cause you know the lion hunts actually
the lion sleeps all day the one that
hunts
is the she lion
and that's the fact
so
yeah but the alpha wolf is the leader of
the pack that's not real captivity
that's that's not real
that's not real that's not real
just stop if he's too weak and too beta
to approach a woman on the
internet beta beta ain't she like 39
yeah single yeah
she on youtube and she hiding her sub
count because she keeps losing folks
you call yourself a feminist
it's just nonsense i'm not saying he has
to walk across a crowded cafeteria like
climb a mountain to meet her
there it is if he can't do that
why are we and i've said this before
closing the gap between who he is as a
man and who he needs to be
why why is that our job why is our
manhood defined by the ability to
approach you
why is that your idea of masculinity our
ability to approach you
when you don't even match the
traditional ideas of what it means to be
feminine
there's nothing submissive about you and
it's okay
but i just so find it so funny that
you're like men be the traditional
go-getters okay
go go go get them go i'ma go get mine
too though [ __ ] you wear the pants
and then you asking us about her
trousers because you know what guys
don't do it for us
who we are as women
rest on our shoulders no matter what
what's a guy going to do is he going to
go on birth control no
is he going to get pregnant and have the
babies no that is going to be you and it
will be you and this is women's work
forever you can talk all you want about
gender roles and i'm a feminist
girl if you think doing a man's work is
feminism and equality you have been
bamboozled by the patriarchy that is
more
oppression so because women get pregnant
bro
bro so because women get pregnant men
have to approach bro this is the part
where i rattle off about the fact that
men do every dangerous job in the world
bro is this the part where i rattle off
the fact that listen men have to
sacrifice themselves in the case of
emergency kill them
will we suffer most of the physical
crimes tell them yes violent crimes
predominant victims are men wow
do we go well because of that you know i
mean [ __ ] you gotta stay in the kitchen
cause you know we still out here dying
in these streets you get me cuz
you feel me nah bro nah bro real talks
and [ __ ] pulled a gun on me last week
so [ __ ] uh put on the apron are you
good no no bro i'm just saying like i'm
out here dying [ __ ] we out here dying
for real die for the [ __ ]
true
nah bro i'm just saying though like yo
that's crazy dog
it's like
it's like how's it like
[Music]
you
bro
i'm just saying man
i'm just saying i'm just saying like yo
women's selective feminism is crazy to
me it's like for oh for thousands of
years we were oppressed and now we
finally came out from under the
patriarchy and got our own jobs and you
know now we can take control we got
birth control so we want to casually we
can enjoy our own sexuality and be sex
workers and [ __ ] shamers out the window
and all this other stuff and then when
it comes down to some like approaches
like uh the last 2000 years were fine
[Laughter]
y'all killing me y'all killing me man
this is goofy talk it's really selective
it's really goofy talk there are certain
inalienable truths about men and women
in our society that we cannot dismantle
right this moment and reaching out to a
guy and chasing him isn't how we do it
girls it's not we dismantle that
patriarchy by stopping and saying
no
i'm worth more than this yes you know
what you're right
we stop the patriarchy by giving more
power to man
you know
it's just crazy
bro
yeah let's lose our agency at a time
where people are dying alone more than
ever where people are having a hard time
finding a mate your advice to ladies is
to not take control of their own
situations no and that's how
you get okay you get power by giving it
away okay you are not going to behave
this way and if you do you're not going
to do it in my life you can go do it in
another girl's life who doesn't
understand her value we're here to
understand our value we are here to
create a society and a relationship that
is worthy of our standards right
but you know what
some of you guys probably like bumble i
can hear i can hear the comments now
well thank you i met my boyfriend on
bumble okay hey maybe i don't want your
boyfriend
you want any boyfriend you out you're
struggling at your age
anyways
yeah i know two girls who met their
husbands off bumble and then i asked him
i was like
why exactly were you on bumble because
here's my theory
and he said i liked bumble because i
felt like the girls on there were more
serious
and here's something interesting which i
had like never
considered until i started talking to a
lot of guys who are on dating apps is
one thing they run into a lot is girls
who are on dating apps only just for
attention but they don't actually ever
want to meet up
this like blew my mind because
like
that's the opposite of what i want to do
it's not because it's the opposite of
what you would have do that it's not
happening
i mean i mean that what you just said
right now doesn't mean no it blew my
mind it's the you're not necessarily the
norm boo boo honey chicken can we all
appreciate for a moment
my girls out here giving advice to
ladies and she don't even know ladies
she don't even know how ladies move the
fact that you don't know that ladies do
this online is mind-blowing to me women
do it on instagram they'll do it on
facebook they used to do it on myspace
they used to do on msn plenty people are
just starving for attention it's a
currency
so the idea you don't know that ladies
would do this on dating apps to me is
like it shows me that you are not
knowledgeable about this stuff my other
friend who got married off bumble
oh
i think she was
like a director casting a role in a play
it's time for a husband check
she met him and got married within a
year
i think that's a little sus like that is
just so fast and she's like well i'm
older you know i want to have kids i'm
like that's not bumble though
that's your friend
don't put that [ __ ] on bumble
she had her reasons
she chose to do that she did it ain't
got nothing to do with bumble
bumble was the accessory for that
she's about to use these anecdotes to
just create a bumble yeah
she was checking boxes
and i think her relationship with this
dude is
alpha and beta they don't seem like
equals he seems very like okay whatever
yeah they don't seem like equals just a
few minutes ago you talk about men and
women are not equals few minutes ago
number in the same video boo boo honey
chicken in the same video you talking
about men are not equal to women we're
never going to be equal we're not equal
we're not equal and now you're like
they're not equal
you know what kills me yeah
and what have i always said about dudes
passive reciprocation right it's easy to
find a guy who's like
sure i'll respond to your message sure
you can come over and hook up with me
sure whatever but they're not actively
pursuing you and then one day he ghosts
out and you're like oh my god what
changed and the answer is nothing
changed he wasn't pursuing you then he
wasn't pursuing you now he merely
stopped that passive reciprocation he
just locked the door the door was never
opened and he was walking through it to
get you he just unlocked it and let you
do all the walking
so that
their relationship that i observe is a
lot like that he seems kind of like a
beta male who's just like okay okay okay
and you know what for some people that
works if you're kind of ticking those
boxes where you just want to like get
get you need to get married because your
sisters are all married and you need to
have a baby because everyone else in
your family has baby then like that sort
of construct
is probably fine for you
it is not fine for me and if you're on
my channel and if you're one of my
subscribers i dare say it's not fine for
you either imagine someone settling and
then finding their little piece of
happiness or joy
right wearing something that maybe is an
ideal or to their perfect liking or what
they imagine but they make it work you
know what there's beauty in that
you know why because maybe over years
you guys develop a deeper sense of love
for appreciation of all the things you
didn't think you wanted a partner
yes that happens to people all the time
it happens in work relationships it
happens in friendships and it happens in
just regular dating relationships
she's basically subscribing to the yes
queen mantra right where it's like [ __ ]
we don't settle out here we queens we
out here doing our thing we bad [ __ ]
right play a little salsa music for me
okay
yeah i know where i got this energy
where do you think i got it from how you
doing shaolin right
so
she subscribes to that kind of mantra
but that's not a reasonable way to live
life
this whole idea of life is my way of the
highway
that's too rigid for the human
experience and i'm just talking about
dating in general talking about life
you can't go into any business and
saying i'm going to have it this way if
you know anything about running a
business you know that there's a lot of
curves there's a lot of bending that you
have to do you don't necessarily break
but boo boo you don't have to bend
you're gonna have to bend to accommodate
your employees to accommodate your
partners to accommodate uh your
contractors you're gonna have to bend
you're gonna have to pay more
you're gonna have to outsource right
you're gonna have to compromise you
can't have it your way all the time
that's not a reasonable way to live life
so i have no clue why people come to
dating and think they're going to get
everything they ever wanted
that's a fairy tale
and i don't believe in fairy tales
i stopped believing it
right after mufasa died in lion king
okay i'm like this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
that that [ __ ] you up yeah man mufasa
was a real one he [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
up mufasa was a real one
mufasa was a real one a drop of one in
the chat from the fossa um in the chat
this is my life
it's live when they watching it
they right now leaving comments i
promise you it's about to be a bunch of
ones from
okay
mufasa affected us
yeah they bought them yeah yes put a one
for remember
um great actor james earl jones yes sir
great actor yeah um
so just understand you don't have to be
rigid with things sometimes you have to
do things you don't like trust me most
guys are out here having to approach
women and they're not interested they
don't they don't want to do it it hurts
it's very painful but guess what we
understand the op the idea of compromise
because we understand it's part of the
bargain
right
we're gonna do it and it'd be great if
you guys also compromised not just in
regards to approaching folks but maybe
it's in regards to
other aspects of dating and then in
doing that
again what you're gonna get out of like
building a deeper bond with someone and
willing to sacrifice is gonna be far
larger than always getting what you want
because
whatever you want will never be as great
as
the thing that you and someone else can
build through joint compromise and
sacrifice
and this channel is an indication of
that i've had to make a lot of
compromise and sacrifice same thing for
preach same thing for the people who
work and partner with us oh yeah
absolutely
you know but that's that's that yeah
trust me if i got everything i wanted
this wouldn't look that way no same way
if you got everything you wanted this
wouldn't look this way no right
but doesn't mean that you can't make
something wonderful out of a situation
that isn't
ideal bro so i just want to leave you
guys out on that closing note i suppose
is there anything else oh i don't know
i was done a long ass time ago
all right you hear that
it's a siren that's a police
that's my cube
at any rate let us know what you guys
think the comments below we want to hear
from you
[Music]
me